Miss America pageant announced they are
eliminating the swimsuit competition
they're doing this in an effort watch it
watch it
let's keep up with the times fellas yeah
I'm keeping the audience with oh boo now
they're eliminating the swimsuit
competition in an effort to keep up with
the times and modernize the entire
pageant I think it's a good thing
they've decided yeah why not they've
decided to replace the swimsuit
competition with a series of events
highlighting essential skills for
today's young women here are some of the
things they're considering take a look
this is the dawn of a new era at the
Miss America pageant that's why we're
moving away from the swimsuit and
launching a new event that will
highlight the important skills that
young women must learn today skills like
competitive podcasts are going to be
talking about what it takes to be a
modern woman and a zookeeper beyond
avocado toast other types of toast
texting in crosswalks arguing with men
about Star Wars on Twitter
avoiding people named Harvey and finally
using a deadly art of Krav Maga to exact
painful revenge on your enemies this is
the new face of Miss America
[Music]
[Applause]
you